one of the really interesting things
online video has done is it's changed
the marketplace for ideas gone to the
days when just a few talking heads set
the agenda for our national discussion
today anyone can upload their big ideas
to the Internet and have a chance of
being heard but how do we access all
this information in a useful way one
group on YouTube has done a good job of
bringing some order to this cat extreme
of ideas as a group called big think now
their mission is to take the national
dialogue away from talking heads and to
give it back to you the methodology is
interesting they get a bunch of experts
in fields sit down for long interviews
and they die set those clips in a
different idea segments and allow the
public to watch and rank them and also
submit ideas of their own now big things
YouTube channel has over 100 such videos
hub together and the founder of big
think Victoria Brown was nice time sit
down with us for a short chat about the
site Victoria thanks for joining us and
I guess the first question is why did
you decide to start big thing well we
sort of saw a need on in the internet
landscape for a place where thoughtful
content could be found and users could
engage with it so instead of users just
uploading videos in response to nothing
we thought that we could create a space
where we catalyzed the conversation with
thoughts and ideas from some of today's
most amazing thinkers from every walk of
life from science and technology to
policy and politics to business and
economics and so it was sort of there
was sort of a dearth of thoughtful
content on the internet and we just saw
an opportunity to create some you have a
lot of great guests on big think
everyone from Grover Norquist to Arianna
Huffington to Gloria Esteban tell us how
do you select the guests for the site
and how do you convince them to
participate well so we have two ways
really of choosing guests we sort of
think of about it is this a topical idea
or is this an evergreen topic and so for
our topical ideas for instance this
being an election year we've interviewed
a lot of the presidential candidates so
from the Republican side we interviewed
John McCain and
Romney and on the Democratic side before
these this sort of frontrunners were
chosen we had done governor Richardson
and several others Dennis Kucinich etc
and we try to think about whether the
issue is topical and how long you know
we have an in lead time to get these
people and then if it's an evergreen
topic which most of the content on big
think is it's more more about is this
what what is the expertise of this
person and how can we bring that out and
how can we make it accessible to our
users and in an hour provide them with
the most important information that we
think this person can provide in an hour
of their time now if your staff are the
ones who are actually interviewing these
guests how are you eliminating the
mainstream media filter from this I mean
aren't you asking the questions just
like the media would well I don't know
that we look about look upon the
mainstream media as a bad thing it's
just that we do things a little bit
differently and instead of asking just
the most pressing questions in the minds
of the media that day for instance you
know when if Tom Cruise were to come on
asking him about his most immediate
relationship quora query we'd ask him
much more about what he does and his his
profession and his area of expertise not
so much about you know something that's
in the news for two days and then is out
of the neatest Victoria who would you
say is your most interesting guest that
you've had on big thing so far well it's
sort of hard for me to say that because
we've interviewed so many people as i
mentioned from the arts and science to
policy and politics to string theorists
and so I'll name a few of the the more
interesting ones everybody has been
actually has been great but I think sir
richard branson gave a great interview
and spoke a lot about the environment
and what he's doing to help but that was
really good Senator John McCain spoke
about the presidential election process
and how he came to be where he was and
it's interesting we interviewed him in
december and so he still had some time
to go and so it was right in the midst
of midst of things and so seeing his
thinking then is pretty interesting and
we'll see what he says later and i also
think some of our physicists have been
incredibly interesting like Lisa Randall
she was really really great and kind of
put a simple spin on what she does so
that average people or the normal person
can understand a stand it and that's
really what we try to do these are some
of the most smart people in the world
and we try to make what they do
accessible to our audience now of all
the ideas topics that you have in the
site which ideas would you say have
gained the most popularity on big thing
well it's been surprising actually
because we thought that what would spur
the most responses would we are most you
know famous participants but it's
actually turned out to be that the
conversation really is taking off driven
based upon the idea and so we've had a
lot of responses to spiritual type
things and our faith and beliefs section
of the site really has a lot of
commentary on it we've also had a lot of
responses to our business and economic
guests and that's I think in large part
because of the insecurities about our
economy at the moment and going forward
I think as things change we'll have more
and more responses to different areas on
the site also the green area has been
pretty robust as well okay two final
questions one do you have any
interesting guests coming up to be
interesting to let us know about yes
well in the field of politics we have
nancy pelosi coming on we're also going
to be working on an entertainer series
with a lot of top-level entertainers
from the fields of acting and music we
also have a lot of great poets including
CK Williams Nobel poet laureate Billy
Collins we've had Jonathan Franzen on
and I think we're essentially going to
be continuing what we've done I'm trying
to get as many amazing people from
across the gamut of professions and so I
don't want to name too many people
because I think everybody that comes on
is is pretty spectacular how will you
know if big thing has succeeded I think
that if we hear about it you know
you go to a cocktail party and people
are discussing something that they've
seen on big think and basically if it
becomes part of the fabric of
conversation I think that will be some
big way to show that we've been
successful but also that just people are
using it and it's growing in its user
shape on an ongoing basis